thank you
[Music]
and welcome back everybody we have
several tragic cases making headlines
all with one common theme innocent
shooting victims being at the wrong
place at the wrong time 65 year old
Kevin Monahan is charged with
second-degree murder after shooting and
killing 20 year old Kalyn Gillis on
Saturday officials in Upstate New York
say that Gillis and three friends were
looking for another friend's home when
they turned around in Monahan's driveway
Monahan fired two shots at the car
hitting Gillis the sheriff says no one
had gotten out of the car at the Monahan
home and they appeared to be turning
around to leave because the area is so
rural this group apparently had to drive
several miles before they had enough
cell phone service to actually call
9-1-1 when deputies got to Monahan's
home they say he was uncooperative
Monahan currently sits in the Warren
County Jail without bond
a similar incident occurred just three
days later in Elgin Texas shortly after
midnight on Tuesday four cheerleaders
went to a supermarket parking lot they
used a lot for carpooling purposes after
practice and police say that Peyton
Washington and Heather Roth were shot
after Roth entered the wrong vehicle
mistaking it for one of their own
authorities say that the man in that car
got out and opened fire he has been
identified as 25 year old Pedro Tello
Rodriguez Jr he has since been arrested
and charged with deadly conduct a charge
that carries a sentence of up to 10
years in prison the investigation is
still ongoing and officials say that
more charges could be added at a later
date Roth suffered minor injuries and
was treated and released at the scene
according to a GoFundMe page for
Washington she remains in stable
condition in the ICU after suffering
organ damage and other serious injuries
the page has raised over one hundred
thousand dollars as of Thursday
afternoon for medical expenses
now unfortunately it does not stop there
that same Tuesday a six-year-old girl
and her parents were shot in North
Carolina after a basketball rolled onto
a neighbor's lawn a group of children
were playing outside in the neighborhood
just before 8 PM when the ball rolled
into the yard of 24 year old Louis
Singletary when six-year-old Kinsley
white went to go retrieve it from his
property police say the suspect started
shooting striking the young girl and her
parents White and her mother were
treated for minor injuries and released
from the hospital but the young girl's
father who was reportedly shot multiple
times is still hospitalized with serious
injuries authorities say the 24 year old
suspect is still at large and is
considered armed and dangerous he's
already facing several charges including
attempted first-degree murder Brian the
two shootings that involved cars if they
go to trial how would they differ or how
would they be the same I think they're
going to be the same in the sense of
they're in cars and they're getting shot
at I I don't see a potential defense for
the two Texas two Texas cheerleaders
were shot because while they did enter
the vehicle they didn't leave and then
the person who shot then got out and
shot them so what's the defense there
like what are you arguing that's that
just seems like blatant serious assault
with a weapon and in the sense of of
Gillis on the uh turning into the wrong
driveway then backing out we are here
later on that he supposedly told
neighbors that he was irritated by
people being in his driveway and he was
looking forward to doing exactly this I
think those text messages May negate any
if there was ever a possibility of
self-defense which I don't see uh
argument there so I think they'll be
similar to cars but difference in
defenses oh I agree with you that
doesn't really work Terry let's talk
about Robert Singletary so he chased a
family down the street and shot at them
for retrieving a basketball from the
yard how can he claim self-defense well
he's going to try but it's not going to
work and this is probably of the cases
we're discussing the worst it involves a
six-year-old girl and all three were
shot fortunately they all survived but
here he is going to try to claim that
and in North Carolina you do have stand
your ground which means that you can use
Force you think it's going to reasonably
protect you from deadly force or from
getting serious bodily energy and he
can't claim that none of that was
happening here they were looking for a
basketball there's also castle doctrine
in North Carolina and it just means you
can do the same thing if you're in your
home I don't think he's going to be able
to claim that here he was looking for
them he was going down the street he was
shooting wildly it's not going to work
yeah I think those are all really bad
cases for the shooters and just terrible
situations all around across the country
when we come back Repertory Lanes faces
over 20 years in prison for shooting
music artist Megan the stallion in Los
Angeles will his defense team secure
their client a new trial we're breaking
down the arguments up next
[Music]
foreign
welcome back everybody we finished
Today's Show Out in Los Angeles we're
sentencing for rapper Tory Lanez has
been delayed as he fights for a new
trial Lanes was convicted of felony
Firearms charges back in December for
the 2020 shooting of rapper Megan the
stallion while leaving a pool party
Lance faces a maximum sentence of over
22 years in prison that sentencing
hearing was initially scheduled for
January but it's been delayed several
times as Lanes acquired new attorneys
for his case those attorneys Jose Baez
and Matthew barhoma who's appeared here
on the long crime Network follow the
motion for a new trial back in March
they claim that certain evidence and
witness testimony testimony was
prejudicial and that their clients right
to choose his own counsel was violated
the prosecution filed a motion in
opposition to the defense's argument
saying their claims lack substance in a
hearing on Monday Lane's defense said
that they will file a supplemental
response to the motion on May 1st the
judge set a hearing for May 8 to discuss
the motion now if a new trial is denied
the judge expects Lanes to be sentenced
within 30 days of the hearing it's time
to bring back in my co-hosts who've had
a chance to read the court documents in
full from each side Brian will start
with you can give us some specifics on
why Lane's defense team wants a new
trial and is it reasonable absolutely
excuse me looking down because it is an
84 page motion trying to get specifics
in here there's a number of things so
the IG post the character evidence
they're saying uh it went to the theory
of the prosecutor's case they shouldn't
have had it where there's pose so they
don't really know who is the author of
it says that Tory Lanez is lying about
shooting at Mega stallion's feet
inadmissible DNA evidence in culpatory
statements meaning incriminating
statements where he being Lanes or
supposedly saying please don't say
anything I'm on probation he wasn't at
the time so the thing that shouldn't
have come in write to council evidence
of the defensive defenses creative
expression meaning his tattoo his lyrics
the music video as well as a
confrontation clause when it came to
Harris these about five or six different
arguments are what they're saying
amounted to impermissible evidence
coming in and this is why they should
get a new new case they're going to have
the hearing as you said on May 8th the
judge said it should be about a
three-day hearing to see if these
elements rise above that uh that level
of saying you need a new hearing rather
than saying this is harmless error
you're already convicted all right so
that's defensive side it's a shame Brian
doesn't have a photographic memory and
couldn't remember that off the top of
his head but Terry I go to the
prosecution they don't believe that
Lane's entitled to a new trial you agree
if so why I do agree with the
prosecution they are not entitled to a
new trial as you know if the evidence
was wrongly admitted or wrongly denied
then in fact you get a new trial Brian
mentioned the fact that the Instagram
was admitted and the reason that they're
arguing is it wasn't a proper Foundation
it was a proper Foundation he's talking
about the DNA evidence that was admitted
they're saying it shouldn't have been
admitted it was admitted because it was
no objection from the defense so there's
no reason not to admit that the judge
was right on that as well and I do think
that confrontation he had a right to
confront Harris so I think it was all
correct both sides we'll see what
happens Brian Terry thank you everyone
out there thank you we're going to see
you next time as we discuss Justice in
America
foreign